vamos al repaso de las noticias
económicas con Daniela Blandón Daniela
Saludos Nuevamente para usted Hola
Ángela Vamos a continuar hablando de la
Cumbre de la unasur que inicia hoy en
Brasil con nula Silva la cabeza y que
busca relanzar este bloque de Naciones
pues son los presidentes de los dos
estados soberanos de América la de
Sudamérica mejor que se reúnen hoy en
Brasilia para su primera cumbre en casi
una década Con excepción por supuesto de
Dina boluarte quien no puede salir del
Perú la invitación corrió por cuenta del
líder izquierdista brasileño Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva quien aspira a
recuperar ese papel activo de su país en
los asuntos regionales una su recordemos
fue creado por presidentes de izquierda
en 2008 pero se fue desvaneciendo a
medida que la región iba virando hacia
la derecha ahora vuelven a reencontrarse
para abordar entre otros temas la alta
inflación que está afectando una región
donde la pobreza y el hambre pues ya ha
venido en aumento en los últimos años
pero también para hacerle un pedido
oficial casa blanca para que levante
todas las sanciones que tienen contra
Venezuela
es su culpa no es culpa de Estados
Unidos que hizo un bloqueo exageradísimo
siempre digo que un bloqueo es peor que
una guerra porque en una guerra suele
morir soldados en las batallas pero un
bloqueo mata a niños mujeres gente que
no tiene nada que ver con la disputa
ideológica en juego
sueño además con una moneda diferente al
Dólar para que podamos negociar entre
los países que nos venden sus productos
y los que nos compran y los países
hay más noticias Pero esta vez por
cuenta de elon musk que que ya Estuvo en
Europa su siguiente destino en la gira
internacional es china ya llegó allí ya
llegó este Jet privado del dueño de
Twitter tesla y spacex que había pasado
por Francia también por Reino Unido En
días pasados y aterrizó en Beijing en
donde ya fue recibido por el ministro de
relaciones exteriores y prometió que va
a expandir sus negocios allí y no es
para menos este país es clave para El
fabricante de vehículos de lujo tesla
porque su segundo mercado más importante
después de Estados Unidos y también la
planta de Shanghai es su centro de
producción más grande también hubo
espacio para un guiño político según la
cancillería china elon musk fue enfático
en que Washington y Beijing no deberían
cortar lazos económicos a propósito de
las más recientes rencillas comerciales
entre estos dos países y el dato curioso
es que El Magnate no ha podido informar
sobre su viaje a través de Twitter esto
porque Twitter está prohibido en China
Aunque sí es accesible para algunos a
través de una red Privada de pronto lo
que él quiera también Es que le
reactiven su red social
Pues yo no creo francamente y menos con
las peleas que hay del lado de tiktok Sí
señora vamos a cambiar de tema
radicalmente porque hoy comienzan unas
discusiones bien importantes sobre la
suspensión del techo de la deuda Nos
tienen en vilo en Estados Unidos durante
toda esta semana claro y vamos a seguir
muy pendientes todos estos días de qué
pasa con este acuerdo que ya fue
alcanzado por el presidente Joe biden y
el líder republicano Kevin mccarthy Para
que se suspenda ese tope que hoy tienen
de endeudamiento que es de 31,4 billones
de dólares lo que pretenden es suspender
ese tope que se puedan seguir endeudando
y evitar caer en un default en los
próximos días Lo más difícil sin embargo
es convencer ahora los miembros más
extremistas de cada bloque para que no
tumben el proyecto de ley de 99 páginas
ya que algunos de ellos creen que se
dieron demasiado en esta negociación hoy
el primer examen será en el comité de
reglas de la cámara que está compuesto
por nueve republicanos y cuatro
demócratas y de esos 9
observadores tres son del bloque más
rígido así que será difícil superar a
esta etapa pero si lo hacen pueden pasar
a la votación en las dos cámaras en
pleno con el reloj desde luego en contra
son sólo seis días los que nos quedan
Daniela vamos a los indicadores Wall
Street precisamente retomó operaciones
después de un lunes festivo muy movido
en el resto de mercados la bolsa de
Nueva York abrió al alza con la mirada
fija en las negociaciones sobre este
techo de la deuda el índice nasdaq que
es el de las tecnológicas está impulsado
por empresas como nvidia ese es el
primer fabricante de chips próximo a
unirse al club de quienes tienen más de
un billón de dólares en capitalización
bursátil capitalización bursátil es lo
que cuesta cada empresa en la bolsa pues
está por encima inclusive de meta
platforms que es la matriz de Facebook
vamos a Europa en donde las bolsas
operan mixtas con las acciones europeas
y las acciones tecnológicas y bancarias
a la baja y a la espera de lo que pase
en Estados Unidos porque también les
afectaría a ellos y en Asia hay leves
variaciones con los analistas apuntando
una preocupación por lo que podría ser
una posible segunda ola de casos de
covid 19 en China cierro con un dato
puntual Turquía la lira turca cayó 1%
frente al Dólar y marcó un nuevo mínimo
histórico mientras está especulando
sobre la conformación del nuevo gabinete
de reviepta hiper noana Daniela
Muchísimas gracias a usted nos vemos
aquí mañana Claro que sí